America's greatest hero Kyle joined
street fighter 5 in the next update and
ahead of his release we got to spend a
little time sonic booming and flash
kicking with him first off it's worth
saying that is probably the least
changed character overall while everyone
has had their inputs and styles fiddled
with to make them more distinct guy all
feels largely the same he's the game's
first fully charged character with no
quarter half or whole circle motion
inputs so if you played him in three
fire four he'll be very comfortable with
him from the outset overall he's a
little more open to being played as an
aggressive offense character but he's
still also a defensive wall kyle has all
his unique normal attacks and they do
pretty much the same thing as they did
in Street fire for his back fist is a
great way to catch people off-guard if
you cover it with a sonic boom his hop
kick can be steered towards or away from
opponents to keep the pressure on while
moving his forward knee is a super fast
way of getting in and his
gravity-defying upside-down kick will
punish sweeps on top of all that he's
got a few target combos to use as
extenders and as an easy way to get
damaged after a crush counter
these V scale is excellent at
controlling space and getting the
opponent where you want them press the
two medium attack buttons and he'll
leave a small sonic boom directly in
front of them which is handy for keeping
people of you however if you charge your
sonic boom as you're using your V skill
and then execute at the moment the V
skill is out you can send both hurtling
towards the enemy the projectile version
is very quick and gives the sonic boom
two hits of damage or durability
together they make guys viable game very
strong activate geils V skill which is
called solid puncher and you get some
sweet yellow rave wristbands on top of
that you can do a sonic boom and spam
the other punch bonds to follow up with
additional sonic booms the speed at
which these travel depend on the punch
by on your pressing with the hard as the
fastest and light as a slowest you can
vary these up to exert control over the
battlefield and dissuade your opponent
from jumping over them a maximum of five
of these sonic booms can be on the
screen at the same time and the initial
sonic boom can be executed instantly by
pressing the two heart attack buttons at
the same time instead of using the
chargeback forward motion this is really
good for extending combos and dishing
out big damage in a pinch
the flash kicks as always a very good
range and priority it's worth knowing
that only the e x versions have
invincibility so if you have a habit of
recovering from a knockdown with a flash
kick it will get nullified by throws and
vault I'm normals guy also has two
versions of his critical art in his
normal mode sonic hurricane is great for
dishing out big war damage punishing bad
fireballs comboing and chipping if V
trigger is activated however it becomes
sonic tempest although these moves look
the same it has a greater range and
damage since activating v-trigger stops
time you can use this brief window to
charge up a tempest and land it when
time resumes one big change the goal is
that by holding down and forward he does
a crouch walk this is really slow but
allows you to advance while maintaining
the charge you need to flash kick once
girl is in the hands of more players we
imagine a lot of experimentation will be
done with this to come up with good ways
to set up flash kicks overall girl feels
familiar but has a bunch of really
strong tools it might be too early to
tell but right now he seems like he's
going to be in the upper tail of
characters he's got all the right tools
about her ass the opponent exploit the
mistakes and his own the eager players
he's going to be sending a lot of people
home to be a family man